This is an age where disruptions
are taking place at such a rapid
pace, where the company can go from
leading to bleeding at the blink
of an eye.
>> It's really about designing to
be agile, designing to anticipate
the unknown.
[MUSIC]
>> Almost all solutions to problems
out there have a technology
base to it.
This program is geared towards
executives leveraging technology to
drive change across organizations.
>> From strategic vision
development, innovation,
scaling excellence, this program
will make me a better leader.
>> This program exposes executives
to the cutting edge tools that
are available out there.
For example, design thinking, or
behavior design,
to cutting edge frameworks,
concepts, best practices out there.
>> When we brainstorm,
we put up an idea and
whoever can shoot down the idea
first is the genius in the room.
And through design thinking,
really picked up some great
ways to do brainstorming better.
>> How do we get more rapid in
terms of prototyping and
testing things, rather
than spending six months kind of
building something only to get
the feedback after we launched it?
>> Something as simple as
understanding that we make
decisions generally 95% of the time
based on emotion and instinct.
It's very fundamental and
will absolutely carry value going
forward in probably all aspects of
your life.
>> It's the all star content
from the GSB, no doubt.
And then on top of it,
it's in Silicon Valley.
In one week you really do get to
kind of capture the essence of
what it's like here.
>> One of the great aspects of this
program is that we have time for
discussion so that others who have
similar problems can learn
from one another.
>> It is a completely immersive
week, [LAUGH] and
it's joyfully intense.
>> Changes that are going to take
place in the future in
organizations or in the marketplace
are going to be led by CIOs.
>> I think all these skills will
allow more and
more CIOs to sit at the table with
other C level executives as been
really critical and
driving innovation in a company.
[MUSIC]